for anyone who's been involved in the
piracy community kick-ass torrence or
cat is one of the most classic
torrenting sites in the world right up
there with the pirate bay in fact in
2015 kant became the most popular
fashion website in the world as the
pirate bay suffered from legal
consequences
unfortunately for cat their time at the
top didn't last too long as they started
to experience their own legal issues
soon after nevertheless cat was an
extremely popular option amongst pirates
allowing them to easily secure their
spot in the hall of infamy but as we saw
with the pirate bay founders and mega
uploads founder prosecutors and
copyright holders aren't exactly kind to
such founders after all new zealand sent
their anti-terrorist squad against mega
uploads founder and sweden chased the
pirate bay founders across the world so
there's no doubt that if you found one
of these sites you want to remain
anonymous and that's exactly what cat's
founder tried to do
but prosecutors did eventually find out
who he was and here's what happened next
taking a look back the story of kick-ass
torrent circles back to a man named
artem wallin or at least that's what
prosecutors allege ethnically arthem was
ukrainian but it looks like he lived out
most of his life in poland it's not
clear when exactly artem was born but
given that he was 30 years old when he
was arrested in 2016 we can deduct that
he was born in 1986 or 1987. anyway it
looks like artem was heavily involved in
the piracy community during his teenage
years and it didn't take him very long
to switch from being a user to being a
host as arthum spotted a business
opportunity within the piracy scene
similar to youtube and instagram if you
hosted a piracy site you could display
ads that could drive in revenue and as
you'll see later for cat this added up
to quite a bit of revenue considering
the potential artem didn't waste any
time and he quickly put his coding
skills to work soon after in november of
2008 artem launched kick-ass torrents
initially it looks like arthum tried his
best to avoid issues with the
authorities cat proudly claimed that
they complied with the dmca and that
they would remove copyright infringing
torrents as soon as they were notified
but in reality this wasn't exactly the
case given the context of the site it
didn't take long for users to start
uploading copyrighted content and for
copyright holders to start contacting
cat but they were hit with the same
response every single time
greetings your request has been reviewed
but cannot be processed due to one or
more of the following reasons
most of these reasons were complete and
utter bs reason 4 for example was that
there were more than 30 torrents
mentioned in the claim email if cat was
legitimately trying to comply addressing
such a claim would be a top priority but
cat was intentionally avoiding claims
with a large list of torns probably
because they wanted to draw out the
takedown process and to minimize how
many torrents they lost with each
takedown cat was able to get away with
such outright incompliance for many
years as prosecutors had much bigger
fish to fry but as soon as they took
down mega upload and the pirate bay
prosecutors turned their focus to kick
ass torrents
initially prosecutors started off pretty
light against kick-ass they didn't know
who was behind the site and honestly i
don't think they cared they just wanted
to take down the website and stop the
spread of copyrighted material so in
february of 2013 they started working
with internet service providers to block
access to can't the high court in london
ordered isps to block people from
accessing kick ass torrents and to other
torrent sites the isps did comply and
block access but every time they blocked
access to one domain of kick-ass
kick-ass just moved to another domain
they moved from ka.tt to kitkat.to to
ticketcast.eso ticketcasttorrs.im to
cat.cr and so on and so forth clearly
prosecutors couldn't take down the
website through isps but they were able
to force cad to constantly switch
domains this meant that most people
didn't know what the latest domain was
off the top of their heads they had to
google kick-ass torrents to find the
latest link considering this the motion
picture association of america or the
mpaa decided to work with google to take
down kant they asked google to remove
the correct kick-ass link from google
search results they also worked with
steam to prevent the correct link from
being shared on steam chat this strategy
was actually decently effective as this
resulted in many pirates stumbling upon
malicious copycat sites that were filled
with malware and viruses and this was
the perfect excuse for chrome and
firefox to completely block access to
cad even if you had the correct link if
you tried to access cat through these
browsers in late 2015 you got a message
suggesting that they blocked access to
the site because they don't want you to
download a virus it was definitely not
because they were being pressured by
copyright holders they just wanted to
look out for your best interests jokes
aside though we all know why they
blocked axes
in 2016 chrome and firefox changed their
excuse to fishing concerns but soon
enough neither of them wanted to play
these raids anymore so they opened up
axes and stepped out of the way
by this point it was clear that cat
wasn't just a bug that prosecutors could
squash and move on cat had evolved into
being the world's largest fire sharing
site so prosecutors decided that it was
time to go for the host
by this point the fbi had spent years
trying to unsuccessfully take down cat
so they decided to escalate things to
their real top dogs the irs whether it
be al capone or the wolf of wall street
it's clear that the one entity that you
never want to piss off is the irs many
have pissed off the fbi and gotten away
with it for years but almost no one has
escaped the irs and this was no
different for artem the irs didn't care
that artem was causing billions of
dollars worth of lost revenue for
copyright holders but they did care that
artem was causing losses for the irs
you see artem made money off displaying
ads on can't and many of these
advertisers were american yet artem
wasn't paying sales tax or income tax on
this revenue which was a fatal mistake
in march of 2016 the irs got an
undercover agent to inquire about an ad
on cat the irs agent was able to get in
contact with a cat employee named mr
white
mr white informed the agent that cat
charges 300 per ad per day and gave the
agent payment details to a latvian bank
the agent went ahead and bought a
five-day ad in order to gain the trust
of cat and potentially get more details
clearly the irs had motives behind
paying cat but technically this does
also mean that the irs supported cat
with 1500
anyway shortly after the irs agent
contacted mr white again to buy a more
expensive ad this time he was looking at
a banner ad that cost 1 000 to 3200 per
day
it's not clear if the irs actually made
the purchase but they were able to
uncover a new bank account based in
estonia
using these details in conjunction with
the mutual legal assistance treaty
investigators were able to obtain all
the banking records of these two
accounts
this helped the irs figure out that
artem was making bank off of cat at the
peak cat was pulling in nearly 17
million dollars in annual revenue the
irs wanted their cut and fortunately for
them the bank accounts led to more clues
investigators were able to uncover that
the operation was being hosted out of
chicago and that the servers were
located in canada but the most important
piece of evidence they found was
arthem's ip address they didn't know who
the ipaddress belonged to but the walls
were quickly closing in on artem
artem had no idea that prosecutors were
so close to uncovering his identity so
he continued on with his daily life and
this included purchasing media from the
itunes store ironically the owner of the
largest piracy website in the world was
paying for his own media i guess that he
felt that if he had the money you should
pay for it i'm not sure but this
ironically ended up being the root of
his demise you see investigators were
working with a bunch of companies to
track down the ip address one of which
was apple and when artem made a purchase
on the itunes store using his apple id
and his ip address prosecutors were
quickly able to identify him facebook
was also able to provide evidence that
it was in fact artem and the same ip
address that was operating cat's
official facebook account and on july
20th 2016 the department of justice
proudly announced that they were able to
uncover the identity of artem and that
poland police had arrested him they were
also able to shut down cat's proxy
servers and officially take down the
website prosecutors went ahead and
stacked down every copyright
infringement and money laundering charge
they could think of and these were
pretty severe given that cat had
distributed one billion dollars worth of
media according to rtm's lawyer ira
ratkin they were looking to charge up to
20 years for the money laundering and up
to five years for each count of
copyright infringement rothken did
clarify that he highly doubted that all
these charges would actually go through
but worst case scenario arthur could
have been looking at decades in jail to
make things worse arthur was suffering
from extreme back pain and had to be
taken to the hospital artem describes
that during his trip to the hospital he
was escorted by four policemen with
machine guns and one of the guards told
him that they heard that he committed
three murders hearing this arthur knew
that this was going to be more of a
criminal lawsuit than a civil lawsuit
and he had no intention of sticking
around for the verdict
as you might have already guessed as
soon as bail was posted arthur paid the
amount and fled the country the bail
amount was surprisingly only 108
thousand dollars for someone who was
making tens of millions per year
forfeiting even 10 million would have
been an easy price to pay for freedom
but luckily for autumn he only had to
pay a little over a hundred thousand
it's not clear how exactly arthur left
poland given that his passport was
confiscated but given his wealth i'm
sure he was easily able to find a first
class smuggler
anyway on august 26 2020 the polish
ministry of justice confirmed that
arthem had fled the country and the
extradition proceedings would no longer
be continuing in poland his legal team
would drew from the case after they lost
contact with artem and the art and
prosecution has since been put on hold
in other words as long as arthur was
never caught the case will never reach a
verdict and artham can more or less live
a free life in some non-extraditing
country as for kick-ass torrents today
there are many sites trying to emulate
the original but the consensus seems to
be that none of them are as good as the
original also one of the main reasons
that kick-ass became so popular was
because the pirate bay was taken down so
naturally everyone flocked to the second
best option
but with the part babe basically
becoming immortal there seems to be
little need for anything else still many
missed the glory days of cat and the
community behind it while cat was not
able to become immortal like the pirate
bay there's no doubt that cat will
permanently be remembered as a legend in
the piracy community do you guys think
it's moral to pirate comment that down
below also drop a like if kick-ass is
nostalgic for you and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you